i watched the green knight dude
sup
hey i watched that movie that hollywood
loved the green knight hey
folks wow didn't even mean to
hey didn't even mean to hit the button
hey i watched the green night that the
[ __ ] academy lauded hey sup
[Laughter]
i saw the green knight with that guy dev
patel or whatever from hereditary and
they [ __ ] put him in it the guy's
[ __ ] he's playing a white guy he's
indian dude whatever got no problem with
that one equal opportunity for everyone
but saw the movie and got one quest
sup
that movie man
did you see it
oh man i was halfway through getting
mighty pissed off just like sup
sup i'm watching the movie sup dude stop
i'm watching the movie i'm like [ __ ]
nicholas cage in that one scene that he
had definitely ad-libbed in in the
[ __ ] movie that was remade by uh the
one that used to be harvey keitel bad
lieutenant or whatever and now now he
remade it and it's nicholas cage he
walks into the guy and he keeps saying
sup sup stop the guy's trying to do his
lines and nicolas cage just like sup
dude that's me watching green night
cause hollywood
sup
dude i i
i mean in the in the movie dude all
right so look i'm watching a movie and
i'm gonna get to the london trip i'll
get to it dude
because boy do i have some good [ __ ]
about that and this podcast might be
extra long but dude i'll get to it but
so i'm watching the green knight dude
and in the beginning dude it's king
arthur who's white and then he's got a
nephew that's indian for some reason or
whatever it is don't mean to be racist
but i just said i like kamel so it's all
good dude
sup
now i'm watching the [ __ ] green
knight and
dev patel or whatever his [ __ ] name
is
um that sounds like a color in a crayola
box his name
oh can you get me the dev patel
please the burnt dev patel and so uh so
so i get the [ __ ]
uh
i'm watching the movie and dev patel's
there and king arthur is like dying he's
playing somebody who definitely played a
james bond bill and no question dude no
question this guy played a james bond
villain whoever the king arthur guy is
and all he does is talk miles because
he's dying or whatever a british
and uh dev patel comes and there it's
christmas and they're all making merry
which is a phrase that [ __ ] went out
which we got to bring back dude
and um
while they're eating making murray
um
they're in a circular table and then
this [ __ ] green
tree
giant
knight
comes in on a [ __ ] green horse with a
green axe and a branch
now i'm like okay
but i'm like hey hollywood and alrighty
i'm like okay i'm in dude i'm in i'm in
right
you got king arthur he's probably a
james bond villain and then you got an
in like a [ __ ]
not a white nephew and it's
why but also i'm in dude
and then a tree guy walks in on a horse
that's also green and i'm like this now
this is my kind of motion picture
right i'm not yet at this hey hollywood
sup level i'm not there yet right
so the green giant [ __ ] the green
knight comes in and says
whatever he says this is the gist of it
he says
you know because it's all british and
[ __ ] and it's all it's almost like they
talk like shakespeare and i'm just like
i don't even know what they're saying
but i happen to know because i'm just
horizontal in a pod right at the [ __ ]
jet blue [ __ ]
and i'm watching the thing so
i'm really paying attention there's
nothing else going on
so uh
the green knight guy says to the [ __ ]
defcon no no he says to king arthur one
of your men basically i
he's i'll can we do a game you know it's
like
[ __ ] saw
can we play a game and king arthur is
like as long as it's fun and it's not
you're not coming for any ill will and
the guy's like no i want to i want to do
a game
and so he's like okay and he's like
anyone can
any one of your guys can strike me with
their sword and the only thing i ask
well however they strike me i return the
favor in 12 months
and it's like just say a year but i get
it back then you had to be more
descriptive but okay
but i'm like wow what a stupid [ __ ]
game and the guy traveled how long to
come do this and he's a tree so i'm not
yet at sup level i'm not yet asking
hollywood hey hollywood sup i'm in but
where's this going dude right okay
where's it going so
king arthur says does any one of my men
want to partake in this game and make
merry and i'm like okay and then dev
patel jumps in didn't meet did you know
nobody saw this coming because he was
like he's like a 20 year old or some
[ __ ] and all the men were like maybe
i'll do it and dev patel's like i'll
[ __ ] do it and he comes in and the
[ __ ] tree guy just kneels on the
[ __ ]
ground and that patel's like you sure
you don't want to fight and the tree guy
is like do your worst and [ __ ] death
patella laughs his head off dude
so now i'm like i'm in
man i'm so focused it's like i took
ginkgo
[ __ ] bloba in this pod okay
so i'm watching in the airplane and i'm
horizontal watching this [ __ ] and i'm
just you know there's a little bit of
turbulence but i'm watching the green
night and i'm like oh wow
wow this is really [ __ ] interesting
and it's so odd and i can't believe i'm
not asking a hollywood sup yet
hello hi how much longer till we get
there
so now i'm like sup with this [ __ ]
but the green knight isn't falling down
he's staying on his knees so i'm like
intrigued
you know
and the turbulence lightens up okay all
right all right okay
and the green knight gets up with no
head
he stands up
like it's a chicken
he just stands up like i don't need a
head like a chicken when you lap it off
and they run around they're just like
what
head and he picks up his head
and the head says
meet me in 12 months
and he gets on his green horse
and rides away
some like
hmm
i guess i'm in
better not unravel
but i'm in
you wound it so tight
i'm in where are we going so then
halfway through the movie
dev patel's like guess i gotta go you
know what i mean he's like saying arthur
should i go do this game
do you think he meant it and arthur's
like i don't know it's only for you to
find out and i'm just like don't go
your head's gonna get lopped off he
obviously knows magic
because he walked around and picked up
his head and left and went to his green
chapel that you got to meet him at
and so he's like but it's honorable to
go and deb patel's like [ __ ] yeah i'm
gonna go and he goes dude and the whole
movie is about him going for six days
six nights to try and get to the green
chapel he just meets different people
and [ __ ] he meets somebody that robs him
he meets giants that are just walking
and i'm talking about uh attack on titan
giants and he's like where are you going
and the giant is like
and just keeps walking and it's just
having these scenes around like
willy-nilly and at this point i'm like
sup okay and i google it because i got
the wi-fi it's free at jetblue and i
find out it was a [ __ ] poem that was
written in the year 1400 or whatever the
and i'm like oh dude you're gonna make a
movie that was written by some jerk-off
in the year 1400 and it was just a poem
taking so much liberty
i started reading the poem i didn't even
know what it meant it was like and i'm
like give me a break dude and at this
point i'm looking at hollywood and i'm
like sup and everyone's pretending to
like it because dev patel's in it he's a
hot new thing and i'm like sup though
man
and it got nominated for like 20
different awards and i'm like sup though
man
not just the bafta
sup
no we don't watch this movie so that's
my review of the green
[ __ ] knight
i give it 10
subs
i listened to so many [ __ ] breakdowns
of the movie afterwards man it really
made me question things and i know that
people say well you know a piece of art
a good piece of art makes you talk about
i'm like all right cool whatever dude
but still
stop
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
[Music]